as a tremendously rewarding and
challenging story to work on I think
what I what was most interesting to me
about that story was that it was a it
was an institutional story I think she
became the focal point for this intense
frustration both inside the New York
Times and outside the paper in the
American public about how how how did
the biggest story of in recent years how
did how did the biggest most preeminent
news organizations get it so wrong and
in that story was again of course the
coverage of some Hussein's weapons of
mass destruction and the run-up to the
war and I think she was for whatever
reason became this this focal point for
such this intense frustration and and
that you know two years after the fact
that you know America was tied up in
this war in the main selling point for
the war proved to be false and and I
think she took a lion's share of the
heat and what you really see in covering
a story like that is how institutions
function under duress and an institution
like the New York Times which has a
tremendous amount of institutional
inertia it's sort of an act of
self-preservation that it has to excise
this troubled this element to to for the
good of the whole and she she was she
was you know the paper felt that you
know she had to go for for the health of
the the papers to go forward
it's you know it's it's very you know
complicated dynamic but you know it's it
was never it was not one one factor it
was you know you could it was this whole
stew of factors including desire to
cover the biggest story of the time and
which was after 9/11 was the
administration's case for war it was so
you have those competitive journalistic
pressures you have intense pressure
placed on the paper by the
administration to kind of tow the line
in the summer of 2002 the the critical
stories that The Times did run on on the
administration's case had drone had
drawn intense criticism from both the
administration and the right eye and and
then you had editors who who wanted to
be out front covering the big story and
all those combined channel duties
reporting onto the front page and it's
and it's interesting to note in the the
editors note that The Times printed
after the fact explaining the flaws and
his coverage didn't name one person it
didn't name Judea didn't it named
editors and I think a lot of that was a
was the papers recognition that this was
an institutional breakdown
you